hi I'm Erik Bosse and Avengers infinity
Wars Indiana has left me with one big
enduring question if Thanos his goal was
to save and improve lives across an
overpopulated universe would snap in
half of them out of existence really
help hey don't get me wrong while
driving the congested freeways of Los
Angeles I snapped to the fingerprints
off these freaking things but how
exactly would life for us change in that
doomsday scenario well I've burrow down
and a rabbit holes for every other
infinity war related question I have a
problem I know
so let's frighten ourselves with
extrapolation and ask what if Thanos
does snap really it happened well the
Marvel films have given us a little
taste of the impact there's of course
the initial shock of seeing nearby folks
suddenly fading away into dust not to
mention the mess hopefully half of all
vacuums didn't disappear too there's
also some danger on the streets car
accidents helicopters falling out of the
sky
the eeriness of an emergency broadcast
signal blaring over televisions with the
world overtaken by giant ants and play
drums and wear headphones are no reason
now in Marvel's Infinity Gauntlet comics
that this movies based on they anis to
snap is just as devastating cap has
shaken upon seeing Hawkeye and Cersei
fade before his eyes and he later
realizes that the Fantastic Four black
panther daredevil and some of the x-men
have disappeared too spider-man
witnesses a crowd of people in Times
Square suddenly vanished
including the baby out of a stroller an
airplane crash lands in the middle of
the city and across the galaxy the Kree
and the Skrull empires blame each other
for the calamity and declare open war
though really an even bigger disaster
occurs later when Thanos throws a temper
tantrum over death not smiling at him
and he releases a shockwave that
destroys the west coast and the East
Coast and knocks earth out of its orbit
away from the Sun yeah comics but let's
get back to real life how would our
lives on earth change if half of us
vanished well similar events have
occurred in human history in the 14th
century the pandemic known as the Black
Death killed hundreds of millions of
people around the globe and reduced the
population of Europe by around 50% in
just four years this was a bacterial
infection that could cause anyone to
suddenly drop dead the entire social
order collapsed in 1348 Italian
historian
agnolotti Tura DeGrasso wrote this about
it father
child-wife husband one brother another
for this illness seem to strike through
the breadth and sight and so they died
and none could be found to bury the dead
for money a friendship sounds like a
party
some historians say the black death made
people more religious others say that
society became more nihilistic and
indulgent drinking their lives away and
having lots and lots of sex but it
didn't result in wealth redistribution
as the lack of abundant cheap labour now
allowed a new middle class to capitalize
on new technologies to farm and ship
stuff and I should point out that within
just a few centuries earth was right
back to its old population level and now
seventh centuries later our population
is sixteen times what it was then so
with all this in mind let's look at the
five major ways earth and 2018 would be
affected if half of us turned into dryer
lint first let's talk security would
earth really be less dangerous with half
of us suddenly gone yeah sure I guess
you could argue that a random culling of
50% would theoretically mean half as
many terrorists murders and killer bears
but also half as many soldiers cops
paramedics nurses doctors firefighters
bear hunters people who save our asses a
pacifist might argue that half as many
soldiers pointing weapons at each other
on earth could lead to less overall
conflict maybe like do you know people
look at even if rival nations don't get
spooked like the Korean the scroll did
the dust did still left their weapons
behind and now those weapons have fewer
trained personnel maintaining them any
idiot could just grab them look I don't
want to scare you but we need people at
their various posts around this planet
just to make sure everything doesn't
blow up like I shudder to imagine the
wrong crew people on a nuclear submarine
vanishing really just like one spilled
coffee away from nuclear annihilation
and really a lot of our general
day-to-day safety depends on people
behind the scenes doing their jobs and
not suddenly checking out like if the
wrong air traffic controller leaves his
post you're gonna see all kind of oobs
booms I saw Breaking Bad season two
so you can sleep easy knowing that at
every moment thousands of projectiles
are zooming past us ready to slam into
us if someone blinks for too long and
they knows just weaponised half of them
okay next let's look at the economic
impact as I mention before one upside of
the Black Death was greater material
wealth for the survivors and that was
Stannis's main argument after all half
as many people mean twice as many
resources for the rest of us a grateful
universe except not really Thanos the
Infinity Gauntlet comics point out that
animals die too pets cattle people gotta
eat and when happens many people have
half as many pets to eat you haven't
changed much and Marvel Studios head
Kevin Feige clarified that half of all
life has vanished
so not just humans of animals plants
fungi algae there's a fifth kingdom and
bacteria any source of food has also
been cut in half
thanks Thanos even the vegans are still
hungry and now you let this on a planet
with more bearing dirt and it's not just
the food itself the whole infrastructure
that supplies your resources to you
would also be greatly disrupted people
who work in agriculture manufacturing
shipping construction foodservice retail
buying anything food clothes hygiene
products it's gonna get it a lot harder
meanwhile the black market is gonna boom
Craigslist is gonna get cut through just
imagine this scenario friar Gus is
pissed because half his workers crops
and chickens went poof in the bear
shipments he does have her delayed
because half the truck drivers dusted in
the middle of their shipments and that
doesn't matter anyway because your
favorite cooked martha waffle house is
gone too so no more breakfast ever but
it doesn't matter because you can't
leave your house the roads are jammed
with abandoned cars and trucks Metro
tunnels are flooded because hey Dana's
laid off half the people who operate the
pumps to keep that from happening and
your electricity is cut off because the
power plants have happens many people
maintaining them and all the nuclear
ones they're about to go boom anyway
it's just gonna be pretty tough to
continue your cushy life watching nerdy
YouTube videos when your power and Wi-Fi
keep dropping out and you're starving
and freezing to death and roving bands
are looting your house but please stay
subscribed but it can't be all bad right
as Willy Wonka taught us sometimes
murdering off surplus humans leads to
the strongest surviving and thriving and
I should point out that many historians
credit the Black Death for
leading eventually to a number of
technological advances like more
efficient plows and better ships medical
advances and the printing press so would
an assist at make our lives cooler in
the realm of technology it's hard to
gauge the potential impact because
remember we'd also be saying half of all
MIT students and NASA engineers half of
all Rick Sanchez's would be justed to
you were people overall means fewer
geniuses knocking their heads together
and inventing better shamwows but if we
apply the history of the Black Death I
think we could expect some technological
upside perhaps surviving humans would be
more invested in researching space
travel and interplanetary defense from
cosmic threats like Thanos in the future
you could argue that society might be
more concerned with staining touch with
their loved ones in case another random
rapture event occurs this could make
real-time communication technology more
in demand
like I feel like within a few years or
Apple watches will constantly alert our
parents where we are and what our pulse
is what we're looking at privacy is gone
it kind of be like that arcangel episode
I'm black mirror actually you know I
think it'll be like every episode back
here but while we're looking at uh
besides let's talk about the environment
because human consumption of natural
resources is another thing that a 50%
culling might help with would fantasies
snaps solve our ecological problems
there have been a number of studies and
thought experiments on what earth would
look like without any human impact it's
all depressingly wholesome way fewer
carbon emissions the air becomes more
breathable the rainforest thrives overly
hunted species like whales would
repopulate but remember that OHS killed
half of all life
so that means half the rainforest is
gone half as many plants to suck in our
co2 and exhale oxygen for us to breathe
those endangered whales with already too
few available mates probably extinct
that one remaining white rhino is gonna
be even thirstier overall crumbly and
abandoned infrastructure will affect
animal and plant life and all kinds of
good and bad ways but I think we can say
that society pumping the brakes in
general would be good for the
environment that is until that ghost
ship Russian nuclear submarine drifts
into Greenland oops
North Pole melted so now Santa's dead
too but genuinely how would culture be
affected by something like this think
about it a random death lottery of half
of everyone you know it'd be very
traumatic and
grief is just so unfathomable it would
manifest in all kinds of weird
unpredictable forms as we saw during the
Black Death Society was pulled in really
two directions a spiritual extreme in
which people would brace the afterlife
thank God they started going to church
Alam Horn and a nihilistic extreme where
hedonist took whatever time they had
left and lived the novel and HBO series
the leftovers explored a very similar
rapture style event and that only 2% of
people vanished not 50% but it's still a
shock and similarly that fictional
society seemed torn between spiritual
forces and nihilistic cult movements
either way our current thought leaders
would lose a lot of influence actually
the ending of infinity war showed us one
world leader came to Chava Wakanda
dusting and across the globe government
leaders disappearing and that's a big
mess but really I just don't see how any
future society would have faith in any
authority system that let them down like
that like if you're a normal guy on the
street the Avengers blew it so I
wouldn't be surprised at all if many an
hour kind of screwed up society end up
turning to Thanos to worship Him in a
weird mix of gratitude but really good
old-fashioned old testament beer please
don't snap again meanwhile knowing what
I know about human nature from reading
reddit there's probably gonna be an
opposing ideology to whatever Thanos
extreme some kind of cult figure who
preaches instead screw it let the rest
of the world burn too obviously probably
someone similar to the Joker from The
Dark Knight and that's probably as fun
as it's gonna get folks because with all
the chaos of this Mad Max style Dark Age
that we're now in there's probably not
gonna be too much time for any other
leisure activities like sports or the
arts or entertainment actually in the
leftovers Shaq and NFL quarterback and
Gary Busey are among the departures
meanwhile in the Infinity Gauntlet
comics Alf is still on TV so a kind of a
mixed bag one interesting side effect
that we might see is a new genre of
entertainment inspired by the dusting
like the Black Death actually led to a
period of medieval art literature and
music that embraced dark gloomy things
like Hell in the Grim Reaper these guys
were the og Goths there's a rumor that
the ring-around-the-rosie nursery rhyme
dated back to the plague with the lyrics
a tishoo a tishoo or ashes ashes we all
fall down depend on whatever version you
learned those are referencing the
sneezing of the infected and how
they would burn the bodies to try to
stop the disease fun
so with this channel still exists in the
post snap world he could look forward to
our breakdown of all the easter eggs he
missed in hungry Henry for where Henry
escapes the Thanos cult and falls in
love with a pile of dust before getting
oops boomed by a rogue nuclear ghost sub
it's a comedy now I should also point
out that all the horrors that we
experience here on earth in the
aftermath Atlantis is snapped or being
suffered on every other planet with life
that might be out there in the Marvel
Universe there are the Kree and the
scroll in pyres and they're just as sad
as we are as well as godlike cosmic
entities who couldn't care less what
further damage they do the galaxy as
long as they can get back at Thanos so
really these oops booms are just
beginning here's my question for you
guys in this hypothetical
post-apocalyptic world who would be the
leader you look to for guidance all my
teeth danos they're surviving Avengers
those losers that nihilistic Dark Knight
Joker figure I talked about Alf comment
down below with your thoughts your shape
now a big thanks to Marvel Puzzle quest
for sponsoring this video
Marvel Puzzle Quest is a match-three
puzzle RPG that you can download for
free on your mobile device or steam it
features over a hundred fifty characters
from the Marvel Universe and you can
create your own dream team of heroes and
villains and not just the ones from the
Cinematic Universe either like I have
black panther but also venom and
Deadpool dream team you can compete in
vs tournaments as well as story events
and you could join alliances to rank up
in the leaderboards and earn cool
rewards there are any new characters
constantly cabled Domino and Bishop have
recently joined in on the fun as the
latest characters and the Marvel Puzzle
Quest team has a ton of new events and
content coming for the holidays so stay
tuned to see that and here's a special
offer for new players just download
Marvel Puzzle Quest using the link in
the description below or head over to d3
go.com slash new rockstars and get
yourself a three Thanos cover to adhere
collection and follow new rockstars on
Twitter and Instagram add new rockstars
and for more of my insane theories you
can follow me on Twitter and Instagram
or breakdowns of everything Avengers
related thank you for watching and damn
that abandoned nuclear sub keeps
drifting over here just just go up
[Music]